operation speak is underway at UNLV Mary
Jane beliesza explains why a group of
Filipino students is trying to bring the
native language of the Philippines to
campus
language it's an important part of one's
identity and culture for the Philippine
ex-american Student Association at UNLV
learning Tagalog the official language
of the Philippines has become a mission
Jax Milan is the cultural and political
Affairs chair he says it's not just
about language but preserving and being
proud of your culture when immigrating a
lot of that comes with assimilating and
so a lot of people had to assimilate and
be accustomed to the norms and values of
the US culture and so part of that is
losing part of your language and
especially Tagalog according to unlv's
website 18 percent of faculty and staff
identify as Asian or Pacific Islander
and UNLV has over 16 percent of students
who identify as Asian or Pacific
Islander 2. I think this is a very
important step towards inclusivity this
is why President leor dumanlang says
it's important to have Tagalog language
classes at UNLV UNLV has one of the
fastest growing
um like Philippine Filipino communities
like in the student
kind of world so
um it's kind of surprising as to why we
don't have a Tagalog course already that
you could take for foreign language
credits over the past several months the
students have been campaigning to get
the word out by speaking to
administrators committees and the
community to get involved part of that
step to gaining that sense of culture
again that sense of language is to you
know have this Tagalog course available
to not just people who are from the
Philippines but also to anybody so that
like people aren't are also learning
about our culture as well
we have a link to the
paternity surveys on our website the
apparently offers courses in Spanish
Latin French German Greek Italian
Chinese and Japanese